[Music]
and another monopoly news submitted by
submitted by what oh that's the name
they didn't want to type anything you're
like I don't know they went meta they're
social it's like when your passengers
passport yeah Hasbro has released a
female version of Monopoly with a
feminist twist I've been waiting on it
instead of a shoe it's a high-heeled
yeah I was like there's nothing more
masculine than boardwalk and Park Place
and what's up with [ __ ] oriental
[ __ ] he live there what's up with the
oriental [ __ ] place yeah so outdated
oriental was four things anyway like yes
it's say the word like oriental rugs
oriental flavor just trying to be a fan
or know someone posted me someone posted
a picture me on a Instagram page called
oriental girls how much you wanna bet it
was a white dude that ran I mean really
but was it a bunch of hot girls though
yeah asian chick cool that's a good time
never a part of the hot guys group yeah
oriental girl
no I knew some girls that like my
friends had crushes on you like when I
first they're probably ugly though she
probably hit him up because he's pretty
easy pretty available no bro came out
with MS monopoly I came out of my mouth
really worried is it all hookers no so
this game they're saying it's not the
bottom it says that's like a purse a
shoe the first game where women make
more than men so women will collect 240
monopoly bucks I was crushed at monopoly
yeah when I was always the banker me too
how could you do it because the men were
getting paid more money and during the
game well I was it a dog in the game
does this officially has I like the shoe
to I was always the hat my dad was
always the shoes damn I don't remember
this game I think I played like twice in
my life still back here unless she was
flipping off everyone yeah so they
replaced Penny bags many boards are
apron whatever the guys name is where's
our apron
what is he gonna be out a job she's a
CEO kind of woman she's a Starbucks cup
also she's lazy
she's a diversity hire yeah pretty much
there's a whole subreddit for this for
things that are unnecessarily women
email yeah yeah yeah like emails blogs
they might be bills and really it's
because they know that people are
catching it they're cashing in on it
like it's not about like for that one
fight so they start off making more
money than men in this game so they
start off all right no and every time
you you pass go yeah they will collect
240 and male players will collect
quality you won't win unless we give you
this extra money right guys this is good
because that's just it's called child
support and alimony pay she doesn't look
like she has a kid no but like when she
passes that she's the CEO she does that
time for kids okay it's it's is this
meant to trigger a handout she needs one
my chicken for plastic surgery
the board's glittery cuz women love it I
like that quality okay what is black
glitter
yeah with I don't know if it's the right
way to say it but like it seems like
women are just trying to be men what in
this world in this world in this like
why do they deny feminine like you know
what bothers you design this game best
man show you what bothers you tiff you
know everything the male species pretty
much but this one thing I'm gonna tell
you it really bothers me when people
misconstrue feminism as women coming on
top of men with that like totally that
the whole point and then the fact that
they call it feminism like the media
they're calling this a feminist monopoly
I'm like this is it yeah like why does
the guy have to be homeless just cuz the
girls making more money is like white it
was it like
yeah what is this anyways this is this
lesbian hate monopoly mm-hmm I hate
everybody cuz I'm lesbian
alright so very saying that Miz monopoly
is Leslie monopoly all of the things
surrounding female empowerment so
there's one man you landed on tampon
collect $200 yep
okay so if you put this hold on in their
video where they're promoting this this
board game they had like three little
like younger girls that are in stem
project like yeah yeah damn field yeah
stem field stuff all the [ __ ] that girls
don't want to do yeah
Azusa bleep well that's the thing
they're trying to get more women to be
in stem field I actually really liked
engineering but let me show you
you're weird let me show you the like
this is an edited version of the video
we're talkin Dennis that's a lot longer
so they got like an exclusive preview of
it like really I'm not really touching
music they believe in you and your
invention that's why you've been chosen
to receive a first edition of the Miss
Monopoly game orchards they're just like
the adventures inside this box in
veterinary changing the way we live I
hope that you have fun playing the game
and learn about the women who have
Goines just like you every monopoly box
there's no one two thousand five and
ninety dollars in monopoly money when
you're playing league a part of the fun
- $1 in real money what not but 28 hours
and 580 dollars to tell about you use
this mr. beast a man would have given
them 10 K of the up madam waist minimum
that's how much honey card and games
they do with their game maker has ever
done so don't they give them real money
what they use that money they have no
money to play the game with yeah yeah
there's no game money an inspiring young
entrepreneurs everywhere
well that's tight they don't intend for
people to actually play this game okay
so if there was a Asian guy version of
this then I think it's just like you see
a picture of Asian kid like stepping on
white kids getting to the top and then
obviously it'll be more like money and
just better grades and wait that already
happens so that's true I don't know we
need a whole game for that yeah they
need a whole entire game for this
message
honestly they have so many different
they even have [ __ ] oh what's it
called
Garfield ah police like the literal
normative everything they've Star Wars
they have Family Guy if there's any show
that's doing well they have a monopoly
for it it would be totally fine if they
just didn't add the extra $40 things
yeah that's the weird thing and yeah
like their tagline saying like the first
game where women make more than who
they're living a binary world ooh
[Music]
you guys ever played Monopoly
no no it's fun you there's a chance card
where you can throw your wife down the
stairs if she [ __ ] up
what do you say you see equality do that
in the show no no yeah me too that's all
I like from that show it's too slow it's
very slow I do like the way they dress
it's a atmospherically food and it makes
me want to drink whiskey do you think
it's to try to get more girls interested
in things that they were never
interested in before but who's not
interested in monopoly everybody like
jobs like certain jobs then they're
definitely trying to get more females in
there because I was actually sponsored
by Google to do a video encouraging
people to join STEM careers but I do
also believe in that but I do think you
should do what you want to do not what
like society is like telling you to do
so if you're naturally more drawn to non
STEM careers and I'm not I guess I get
the I get the idea behind pushing it is
because like most people growing up I
guess in our generation like you didn't
see many women in STEM fields and it was
like one out of like 50 or yeah yeah so
I get it but then yeah like if you
wouldn't want to do it again who's gonna
raise children because that's my biggest
question like are the guys can raise
children know what I mean everybody can
raise children but we all know that
women do a better job and in the first
five years they are totally just
dependent biologically yours design yeah
the baby needs to eat right so Michael
eggs were like likes Gio more yeah Hika
hates parts sometimes I see I see tyka
like Gio's trying to give him to Bart
you know and then he's like
I heard it's like that for the first few
years and then eventually they grow to
love dad I think my kids will love me I
do but I think that in the first couple
years before they get to know Nicky they
will like yeah yeah true when they can't
talk yet and I don't yell at them but
also I think what there's this stigma
now of like being a homemaker or a house
mom or whatever that it's not as
empowering or it's like yeah I want to
be a [ __ ] stay-at-home daddy what's
cuz there's no um
you can't like attribute like a dollar
sign which is how our society yeah
that's weird if status to something so
because of that like our mom staying
home raising kids is not seen as like
economically valuable and so therefore
it's like at the bottom but I don't even
know where that stems from because I
never viewed it that there's a lot of
dudes calling girls gold diggers and
it's like well like traditionally in
that role the guy would go out and make
the money and the woman would stay at
home and we always yeah so it takes two
things that's like one woman wanting to
be career people which I was naturally
drawn more to having a career at first
but I'm also have a nurturing thing that
is coming out now in my 30s but it like
like then there's also a bunch of guys
who think that women only want to go
with them for the money because like oh
you're dependent on men for money so
like of course women are like wait no I
don't I don't want to depend on you for
money I can go make my own money and
then they don't want to and then the
third one is there's a there's [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] who who are gold diggers right
well yeah there's such a small minority
but every really it just seems like a
lot because of Instagram it's a culture
of certain women that's all yeah but
it's not it's a gold-digging culture a
woman doesn't have a job then she's a
gold digger but then also they if they
get a job they alway you don't want to
take care of kids how are you gonna take
but I'm a gold giver so I don't care no
one's gonna dig it I'm gonna give it
give me some golf I know what are you
doing any gold okay okay that's why
you're earning it yeah that's what I
talked about on David's podcast too when
you grow up cuz I was taught as a kid to
grow up to be a wife like I had to learn
how to cook clean when everything like
just being a wife you sit down quietly
this is how I eat this how you drink and
then you grow up and now let's like this
huge feminist movement saying well if
you're a housewife you're [ __ ]
useless like why are you doing that you
should be working in a career mold
so now there's like two cultures
clashing with each other at like this
age it's really [ __ ] weak but they're
teaching boys to be husbands to it's not
just women have to slowly like etiquette
and then and then boys can't learn
anything you know boys are being taught
in their own way but it's not like be a
good be a good husband by working
[ __ ] hard and bringing a [ __ ] ton of
money into the family and I think this
is what this is this is the part of the
discussion that's left out right so like
people go oh there's a huge pay
disparity there's guys that are doing
CEO stuff and whatever but I'm like why
are there even crazy guys that's willing
to do the CEO [ __ ] like the competition
is fierce
beyond [ __ ] anybody's imagination
like just me in business and doing
entrepreneurship and things like that
like I would not really wish this life
on no one and the extremes of it or like
people are super successful that's on
some other level of crazy these are guys
that sleep two hours a night and just
work competitive like they're just
insane they get sued a million times
nothing penetrates their mind not saying
that women can't do this but it's a very
imbalanced lifestyle and I'm like that's
a psychopath life that's just crazy
and it's also cocaine cocaine cocaine
yeah it's just crazy but but the pay gap
thing is the biggest bunch of like it's
been the most widely debunked [ __ ]
story maybe in ten years but they're
still but that still gets ya because
they're still instances where there is a
pay gap like in a certain company or
something it's not yet for an industry
it's not a whole thing that's why people
still use that well like like like in
modeling like there's a pay gap that's
like filled tilts towards the women
because way more people don't want to
hire they don't care about the dudes
modeling in tempore oh they get way the
hell thing I thought I thought the
ladies got more I was never taught to
cook or clean or I be a wife or anything
when I was growing up so I had to learn
that stuff later and now when I learned
it I'm like oh now I think I want to
have kids like your [ __ ] wife
thought so and your [ __ ] will [ __ ]
I'd be a good wife to guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]